- That is both satisfying and disgusting.
(energetic instrumental music)
I've seen them on people in shows.
- Yeah, I don't really think
about blackheads that much,
but I do see them.
I do notice them
and I'm like, eh, maybe one
day they'll get out of there.
- I think blackheads, you
can see them very clearly.
You can definitely see it on my face.
- I have never noticed
blackheads on your face.
- Oh, that's nice.
- I like to think I have nice skin.
- I've got like blackheads, I guess,
but they're just enormous pores.
- It sounds like an alright pasta.
Like, I'll have the biore.
- I have my doubts that they will work.
A lot of instructions.
- This looks like an advanced band-aid.
- It's a band-aid from the Fifth Element.
- Thoroughly wet your nose.
So I should wet my nose first, right?
Just a little dabble.
- Does the nose need
to be soaked or moist?
- Dry hands, peel strip off plastic liner.
- Oh, I touched the inside.
I wasn't supposed to, was I?
- This is like the fake tattoo things.
- Am I doing this right?
Screw it, I'm going for it.
- I feel like this is
gonna rip the skin off.
- Okay, so now we wait, right?
(dramatic chord)
- Carefully do this.
Oh.
That is both satisfying and disgusting.
- Guess it's somewhat clean.
- Yeah, you got a clean nose.
- Feels like I'm waxing my body.
Oh, God.
Eww.
It looks crazy.
- It's kinda gross.
A lot of them.
- I wanna see.
- Ow, my eyes are really
starting to water, actually.
It's like.
It definitely pulled it out.
It's like a little forest.
That's really kind of gross.
- Oh yeah, that's intense.
That's a rush, that's intense.
I didn't know all of this
stuff was in my nose.
- I feel 10 pounds lighter.
- Yeah, I feel cleaner.
I feel more pure.
I didn't expect to pull anything off.
I guess I was under the illusion
that I don't have blackheads.
- I mean, I don't know.
I'm nervous that I've
disturbed a balance on my skin.
(laughing)
- Taking it off, I did
kind of feel like a snake
shedding it's skin.
- I probably wanna do this once a week now
that I found out this exists.
- I would do it again if
someone bought me the strips.
(lively instrumental music)
(wooshing)
(squeaking)